there's heartbreak and profound
frustration across America nowhere more
so than at the scene of George Floyd's
death where his brother condemned the
violence of recent days please I know he
would not want y'all to be doing it and
I'm not saying the people here whoever's
doing it relax
demonstrations and destruction have
swept the country curfews ignored as
chaos rules the driver of this tanker
was arrested after speeding into a crowd
of protesters in Minneapolis remarkably
no one was hurt the catalyst for all
this volatility the gut-wrenching
footage of George Floyd's final hours
it's exposed wounds already so deeply
felt over the death of yet another black
man at the hands of law enforcement that
leaves so many others living in fear
it's scary because like usually
sometimes when you see a police people
run incidents like this in Atlanta
Georgia are only Fanning the flames
these two police officers were later
fired for using excessive force against
protesters in Fort Lauderdale Florida
this footage shows a police officer
pushing a kneeling woman to the ground
you can see his own colleagues
immediately react with anger he's now
being suspended
shows a force are what the president
favors made clear in his phone call with
state governance you have to arrest
people in the capital Washington DC
peaceful daytime protests turned violent
overnight with cars and buildings set on
fire a stone's throw from the White
House this is what it looks like today
the mayor is not taking any
answers tonight she's imposed a 7:00
p.m. curfew to try and avoid more damage
and violence before lamenting a lack of
force the president was tweeting his
usual refrains about approval ratings
and fake news what he's yet to do is
address the nation but Donald Trump is
no unifier hopes are high that his words
would have any real impact this 2020
Democratic rival is trying to fill the
empathetic healer void Joe Biden visited
protest sites in his home city of
Delaware the Minneapolis police chief
says that in his mind the other three
officers who have yet to be charged were
complicit in George Floyd's death but
justice won't come overnight for now
shows of solidarity are going a long way
in New York
officers prompted cheers as they drop to
Warren knee to pay their respects to the
black victims of police brutality
somewhere in the despair there's some
very tentative
small hope that George Floyd's death
could be the turning point that America
so desperately needs Amanda Walker Sky
News Washington